bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être en
direct avec nous vous avez donc en suivi
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron première
impression globale d'écouter la première
impression globale est bonne je trouve
que lui-même cic et il était temps à la
hauteur de la situation
il était sobre sur la forme juste sur le
fond et je pense que l'heure est à
l'union nationale c'est là celui dit
lui-même un effort individuel et annie
un effort collectif en se hisser à la
bonne hauteur cette situation tout à
fait exceptionnelle et donc ce soir et
je pense le discours qui seraient les
prononcer et les discours qu'il fallait
que tout le monde entende pour que
chacun prenne la mesure et fassent
preuve de responsabilité dans ses
déplacements
parce que parfois on n'a pas
l'impression d'y échapper
on a l'impression nous mêmes que nous ne
sommes pas atteint mais nous sommes un
facteur de propagation parce que le
virus ne circule pas dans l'absolu ce
sont les personnes humaines qui le font
circuler
donc ce soir c'était vraiment le
discours qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
prononcé donc c'était avec moi
d'ailleurs sur ce bateau avec nous lors
du dernier discours des manuels accroc
vous aviez été assez sévère à son
encontre
qu'est ce qui a fait qu là pour vous il
ya un changement plutôt positif à vos
yeux
disons que dans le premier discours d'il
ya quelques jours il était écouté parler
et il avait annoncé qu'il avait parlé
pour ne rien dire pour pas dire grand
chose c'était la montagne qui avait
accouché d'une souris
je pense que lui-même soit il n'avait
pas pris la mesure des événements et de
la situation ce qui était quand même un
petit peu inquiétant soit ce qui l'était
tout autant
at il voulu instrumentaliser le la
temporalité le teint tôt parce que
évidemment il y avait l'élection
municipale ce qui était un pur scandale
d'organiser cette élection municipale
puisque ensuite lui-même mais tout
l'exécutif et un certain nombre
pratiquement tous les chefs de partis
ont ont proclamé que c'était bien
organisé
ce qui est une hérésie on n'envoie pas
des millions de gens voter et se balader
dans l'état parce que bien sûr tout le
monde alliés après c'était les parcs
mais les parcs c'était un succédané
c'était autre chose c'était en plus il
fallait que les gens restent confinés ce
qu'on peut évidemment regretter c'est
que ce discours
s'il avait été prononcée il y a trois
semaines tout le monde aurait applaudi
et là évidemment c'était bien le moins
que l'on puisse faire de rattraper
autant que possible le temps perdu
le temps perdu ne se rattrape jamais
tout à fait parce que si vous voulez
avec ce qui s'est passé dimanche comme
il ya une période d'incubation qui est
moyenne mais ton de 14 jours nous allons
avoir un pic énorme parce que dans 14
jours parce que tout le monde en se
déplaçant sans en avoir conscience
horace et exploser la courbe et les
nombre de contaminés et ça c'était tout
à fait scandaleux on a vu en a vécu hier
une journée lunaire est complètement
surréaliste c'était criminel donc
aujourd'hui c'était bien le moins
d'essayer de rattraper de rattraper les
choses et et enfin pour la première fois
pour la première fois de son quinquennat
il est apparu à la hauteur de sa
fonction maintenant il faut que ce soit
suicidé c'est parce que monsieur macron
est un très grand acteur
de théâtre donc là il faut il a prononcé
un discours c'est très bien l'heure est
à l'union nationale il faut pas
polémiquer
parce que ceux qui vont polémiquer ce
soir par rapport à ce qui a été dit ce
soir seront disqualifiés parce que
maintenant tout le monde doit faire cet
effort et d'efforts qui a été annoncé
pour pour l'état de la part de l'état
est conséquent il faut quand même avoir
dans l'esprit que l'état c'est vous
c'est moi c'est nous tous mais de toute
façon c'est nous qui paierons tout le
monde paiera mais pour l'instant il faut
il faut passer ce cap difficile et c'est
très bien d'avoir suspendu tous les
textes en cours c'est très bien d'avoir
suspendu la réforme des retraites
et c'est très bien d'avoir rappelé les
gestes élémentaires qui au bout du bout
vont sauver des vies mais effectivement
ce que l'on peut regretter et regretter
amèrement quand même c'est le retard à
l'allumage ces trois semaines qui nous
font défaut et qui aujourd'hui nous
conduisent à cette situation
je rappelle et lui même l'a dit qui
tirerait tous les enseignements
je rappelle quand même que sur beaucoup
puisqu'on est sur une chaîne de télé de
schengen ce crime mais passons la vôtre
parce qu'on a toujours pu parler en
toute liberté et je tiens à le signer
d'ailleurs c'est l'idée rareté des dans
laquelle je m'exprime
on a eu beaucoup de d'experts en bois de
pseudo scientifiques qui sont des
millions d'euros à la une de magazines
en se prétendant médecin et je citerai
pas de noms parce que ça ferait trop
cruel et qu'encore une fois l'heure
n'est pas à la polémique mais ces gens
là ont une lourde responsabilité dans la
situation qui nous expliquait il ya
encore une semaine que c'était une
petite gripette et que dans quatre jours
après quelques degrés de fièvre nous
serons remis sur pied et donc live où il
y aura beaucoup d'enseignements à tirer
sur l'union européenne
ça c'est sûr sur la dépendance à la
chine sur le protectionnisme et les
frontières au sens large comme au sens
strict et sur cette médiane eastman
stucki qui dispensent d'aider des
discours et qui donne des conseils qui
sont des concerts des conseils qui mène
les gens à l'abattoir
justement vous pariez de frontières
cette mesure fermeture de tous les pays
des frontières de tous les pays de
l'union européenne pour 30 jours sauf
évidemment pour les français qui
voudront revenir deux pays'' étrangères
va ça n'arrive pas trop tard selon vous
ben c'est toujours trop tard mais si
vous voulez on va pas rajouter du
désordre et c'est pas parce qu'on est en
retard qu'il faut pas prendre le train
en marche si on arrive à prendre le
train en marche et limiter un tant soit
peu la propagation du virus puisque
aujourd'hui les spécialistes que ça avec
les l'on dit l'épicentre de ce virus
c'est c'est vraiment l'europe il faut
limiter
évidemment la propagation de ces virus
parce que de toute façon le virus n'ont
pas de frontières classé très clair il
faut pas jouer sur les bouts des en
limitant les filets évidemment l'été
platement on va limiter aussi la
pandémie et ne pas contaminer d'autres
continents il faut maintenant être
sérieux on a bien compris le message
vous pensez que ce sont des des bonnes
mesures un bon discours avait souligné
effectivement le report à l'abandon en
tout cas temporaire des textes notamment
la réforme des retraites que vous
combattiez comme de nombreux français
d'ailleurs il n'empêche beaucoup de
rumeurs à ses assurés
d'ailleurs faisait part d'un confinement
total comme en italie le président n'a
pas semblé l'annoncé on aura les détails
avec le gouvernement c'est une demi
mesure pour vous vous l'avez compris
comment non je pense que déjà là avec ce
qui se passe je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
nous sommes dans la riposte graduée et
je vous avez vu comme toul où les
français aujourd'hui que certain nombre
de nos compatriotes ont pris en pleine
face la réalité le réel et ont changé
leur comportement petit à petit les
entreprises se sont vidés et tout le
monde a joué le jeu
les transports en commun se sont vidés
et le pays va s'arrêter progressivement
je pense que les pouvoirs publics ont
fait le choix
de laisser aux français le temps de
s'organiser de quitter évidemment dans
des circonstances un peu un peu organisé
leur lieu de travail pour peut-être
aller dans des maisons familiales où on
pourra être plus en sécurité
essayez de ne pas se concentrer dans des
îles qui sont des nids forcément à virus
1 puisque c'est bien beau de le dire ne
respecter la distance de sécurité
mais quand vous prenez et que vous
n'avez pas le choix un transport en
commun que vous êtes collés les uns
contre les autres c'est un facteur de
propagation du virus donc je pense que
ce délai c'est un délai raisonnable
c'était un coup de vis assez important
et je pense que on n'est pas
complètement la fin du processus et que
évidemment je pense qu'il fera d'autres
annoncé qu on ira vers le confinement
total mais ça permet de ne pas augmenter
la panique vous avez vu les files
d'attentes aujourd'hui dans les
supermarchés et cetera parce que là nous
sommes dans l'irrationnel et moins un
peuple et préparer surtout quand vous
avez des médias qui toute la journée
leur dise que tout va bien
le gibus est intelligent et que les
français ont plus intelligente que les
autres peuples parce qu'ils ont des
barrières naturelles fait de neurones
fait de neurones donc qui empêche le
virus de se propager
donc vous prenez en de plein fouet le
réel et donc il ya eu une espèce de de
réaction de terreur voire de panique et
de désarroi
donc il faut laisser seul sur ce temps
mais je pense que ça va aller très vite
maintenant on va voir ce qui va se
passer demain
il a donné jusqu'à midi et je pense que
c'est clair les jambes vont comprendre
enfin j'espère ce qui nous manque ce qui
est en train de nous arriver
effectivement s'il a la communication
dès le début et si on n'avait pas fait
de politique politicienne pour tenir ces
satanés élections municipales dans tout
le monde savait que c'était un scandale
et dont tout le monde savait qu'il n'y
aurait pas de participation et dans tout
le monde savait que nous serions obligés
et contraints de les annuler pour la
bonne et simple raison que qu'on serait
dans le temps d'un
dans la montée du pic pour le deuxième
tour c'était tout à fait irresponsable
donc ça c'était un regret parce que au
bout du bout ça va faire des victimes
non pas parce que le virus même s'il est
très virulent et mortelle mais parce que
dans des cas sévères
on a besoin de respirateurs on a besoin
d'être un tube et on a besoin de lui et
que les capacités sont évidemment même
si elles sont importantes elles sont pas
infinies fait tout le monde doit le
comprendre
merci beaucoup didier maïsto président
de sud radio nova